The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We ended up the last
lecture talking about
dynamic programming.
And we'll spend all of
today on that topic.
We showed how it could be used
to provide a practical
solution to the shortest path
problem, a solution that would
allow us to solve what
was, in principle, a
complex problem quickly.
And we talked about the
properties that make it
possible to solve that problem
and, in general, the
properties we need to make
dynamic programming
applicable.
So let's return to that
topic right now.
What we looked at is we looked
at two properties.
The first was optimal
substructure.
And you recall what this meant
is that we can construct a
globally optimal solution by
combining solutions to local
subproblems.
So we've looked at a lot of
problems already this term
that have optimal
substructure--
merge sort, for example, which
exploits the fact that a list
can be sorted by first sorting
components of it and then
combining those.
So merge sort exhibited
optimal substructure.
The second property we looked
at was overlapping
subproblems.
And what this meant was that in
the course of running our
algorithm, we would end
up solving the same
problem more than once.
And that is what gave us the
power of using memoization, to
use table lookup instead of
re-computing the solution.
Notice that merge_sort does
not have overlapping
subproblems.
There's no reason that we would
expect, if we're sorting
a list, that we would
ever encounter the
same sublist twice.
And so in fact, we cannot
use dynamic
programming to solve sorting.
Because it has one of these
properties, but not both.
So how about shortest path?
Does it have these properties?
Well, let's first think about
optimal substructure.
You might begin by asking the
question if I knew the
shortest path from A to B, and
I knew the shortest path from
B to C, can I necessarily
combine those to get the
shortest path from A to C?
No, exactly right.
Because for example, maybe
there's a direct link from A
to C. So we can't combine
them that way.
So that gives us
the question--
Oh, pardon?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: --Almost
got it there.
So that gives us the question,
what is the optimal
substructure here?
Well, there is something we do
know about shortest path, that
if I have the shortest path
from one node to another.
And I take any sub path
of that, I will have--
so let's say I have a path
that goes from--
let's say I know that the
shortest path from A to C is A
to B to D to E to C. If this is
the shortest path from A to
C, I know that this is
the shortest path
from B to E. Right?
Because otherwise, I wouldn't
have bothered going through D.
If there were, for example, a
link directly from B to E,
then the shortest path
from A to C would not
have included this.
So that's the optimal
substructure I have, and
that's the substructure that I
exploited last time in showing
you the dynamic programming
solution to the
shortest path problem.
You also recall that we looked
at the shortest path.
We'd found overlapping
subproblems.
Because I would end up solving
the same intermediate problem
multiple times, figuring
out how to get
from one node to another.
So indeed, we saw that the
shortest path problem
exhibited both of these
properties and therefore, was
amenable to solution by the
dynamic programming.
And in fact, we ran it and we
saw that it ran quite quickly.
It's not immediately obvious,
but the 0-1 knapsack problem
also exhibits both of
these properties.
You'll recall a few lectures
ago, and also in a problem set
not so long ago, we looked at
a recursive solution to the
0-1 knapsack problem.
It's called "solve"
in this code.
It uses backtracking to
implement the decision tree.
if we look at the decision
tree we had there--
I gave you a small example
here of the
0-1 knapsack problem.
I've got A, B, C and D. I've got
some values, and I've got
some weights.
We started by saying at the
beginning, we looked at this
node here, where we had decided
not to take anything .
We still had the list A, B,
C, and D to consider.
The total value of our items was
0, and for our example, I
think we had 5 pounds
of material left,
or 5 units of weight.
We then considered a decision.
What happens if we take A?
Well, if we take A, we have B,
C, and D left to consider.
We now look at this node
and say, all right,
our value is 6 --
the value of A. But we only
have 2 pounds left.
We then considered going
depth first, left
first in this case.
This is the depth-
first search.
We've looked at that before.
All right, let's consider
the next branch.
Well the next branch we'll
consider C. Well we discover--
no we'd consider B rather.
We can't take B, because
B weighs 3.
So this is a branch that
we can't get to.
We can elect the other decision
not to take B, in
which case we still have C
and D left to consider.
And still 6 and 2.
We then proceed and said right,
well can we take C?
Yes we can.
And that leaves us with
a value of 14
and no weight left.
So since we have no available
weights, we might as well stop
considering things.
So this is a terminal node.
We then back up, and said all
right, let's consider the
decision where we don't
take C. Can we take D?
And the answer is no because
it weighs too much.
And then we're done.
And so we see on this side of
the tree, we've explored
various possibilities.
And this is our best
option so far.
And we can walk through and now
we consider well, what if
we don't take A?
Well then we have these
decisions to make.
And eventually, we can
look at the whole
thing and make a decision.
By the way, I noticed this
morning that there was an
error on your handout.
I chose not to correct it in
the slide so that you would
notice it was in your
handout as well.
What should node 18 be?
What's the error here?
Pardon?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
That should be the empty one.
Right?
Because we considered
everything.
And in fact, typically all of
your bottom nodes should
either have 0 weights or no
items left to consider.
Not very deep, just a typo but
has the advantage that by
looking for it, you can see
whether you understand how
we're constructing these
decision trees.
So this is a very common
way to deal with an
optimization problem.
You consider all combinations
of decisions in
a systematic way.
And when you're done, you
choose the best one.
So this is using depth-first
search and backtracking.
And this is essentially what you
did in your problem set.
Now what you saw in your problem
set is that if the set
of items is even moderately
large, this algorithm can take
a very long time to run.
How long?
Well, at each level of the tree
we're deciding whether to
keep or not keep one item.
So what's the maximum
depth of the tree?
How many levels can
this tree go?
If we have n items--
Pardon?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: n levels--
exactly.
So if we have n items,
it can go n levels--
Good grab.
All right, how many nodes do
we have at each level?
Well, at level 0 we
have only 1 node.
But what's the down
at the bottom?
Let's say we have an enormous
amount of weight so that in
fact we never run out of
weight in our knapsack.
We'll have quite a broad
tree, right?
How many nodes at level 2?
At each level, right?
Down here we have up
to 4 nodes, up to 8
nodes, up to 16 nodes.
So if we had say, 39, 40 items,
at level 39 we'd have 2
to the 39th nodes--
pretty darn big tree.
All right?
Not very deep, but very bushy.
So we know that for any
reasonable number of items and
a reasonable amount of
weight, this is just
not going to work.
And that's why when you wrote
your problem set, and you were
trying to solve the optimal set
of courses to take, you
could only run it on a small
subset of the courses at MIT.
Because if we gave you
everything-- and we gave you a
lot for a test--
you noticed it effectively
just wouldn't finish.
So now we have to ask the
question well, can we use
dynamic programming to
solve this problem?
And in particular, that boils
down to the question of does
this solution exhibit optimal
substructure and overlapping
subproblems?
Well, optimal substructure is
easily visible in both the
decision tree and the code.
Right?
Each parent node combines
the solution--
We can look at the code
since you have the
subtree in your handout--
or the decision tree
in your handout.
And the key place in the code is
where we combine decisions
from lower down in the
tree as we go up.
So at each parent node,
we select the
better of the two children.
Right?
If the left child is better
than the right child, we
select the left.
Otherwise, we select
the right.
And we just percolate
up the tree.
So there's clearly optimal
substructure here, that we can
solve the higher nodes with
solutions to the lower nodes.
And we see that again in the
code where it says choose
better branch.
It's less obvious to answer the
question whether or not
there are overlapping
subproblems.
If we go back and look
at the tree--
At first glance, it may appear
that there are no overlapping
subproblems.
You'll notice that at
each node we're
solving a different problem.
Right?
The problem is described in some
sense by this fortuple.
But if I've already taken A and
C, and I have D left to
consider, what should I do?
Where up here I've taken A, and
I have B, C, and D left to
consider, what should I do?
And by design of the decision
tree, each node is different.
Right?
We're not considering the same
thing over and over again.
So you might look at it and say,
well, we're out of luck.
There are no overlapping
subproblems.
Not true.
So let's think hard for a second
and ask in what sense
are there overlapping
subproblems?
When are we potentially,
at least,
solving the same problem?
Well what is the problem
we're actually solving?
We're solving the problem that
can in some sense be stated as
follows- at each node, we're
saying what should we do about
the nodes left to consider?
So we're solving a problem
given a set of items--
what items we have at a node.
Given an available weight, which
items should we take?
What's missing from this?
It says nothing about the items
you've already taken.
In order to decide what to take
next, we need to know how
much weight we have available.
But we don't need to know why
we have that much weight
available, which items we have
previously decided to take.
That part of the for tuple turns
out not to be relevant
to the problem I still
have to solve.
Why is that important?
Because there may be many
different sets of items I
could take.
It would add up to the
same total weight.
Therefore, leaving me the
same problem to solve.
And that's the key observation
that tells us we can use
dynamic programming to solve
the 0-1 knapsack problem.
Does that--
I should ask the positive
question-- does that make
sense to anybody?
Raise your hand if
it makes sense--
a small number of hands.
Raise your hands if it
doesn't make sense.
OK.
Can any of you to whom
it doesn't make
sense formulate a question?
No, it's hard.
AUDIENCE: Total weight, or
the same total value?
PROFESSOR: The same
total weight.
Because--
the question is are there many
sets of items with the same
total value or the same
total weight?
There might be many with the
same total value, but that
doesn't really matter.
Because in choosing what to do
next, as I go down the tree, I
don't care what the value
is above the tree.
Because I'll still try and find
the best solution I can
to the remaining subproblem.
If a value above is a million,
or the value above is 3, it
doesn't matter what
I should do next.
AUDIENCE: Which makes sense.
But if you use different things
to get that weight,
wouldn't you have a different
set of items to choose from?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the question is it makes
sense if there are many
different sets of items that
would have the same total
weight, but what
I'm going to--
but, wouldn't I have different
items to choose from?
Well you'll notice that I
do have to look at what
items I have left.
But as I go through--
let's assume here that I have
a list of items to take.
As I go through from the front,
say, I'll label each
node of the tree.
Each item will have either a 0
or a 1, depending upon whether
I decided to take it or not.
And then what I have
to consider is
the remaining items.
And let's say the values of
the first two items--
the first four items--
were, well, let's say they were
all one, just to make
life simple.
Well that'll be confusing, since
I'm using that for taken
or not taken.
Let's say their values
were all 2.
When I get here, and I'm
deciding what to do with these
items, I might--
so this tells me that
I've used up 4
pounds of my allotment.
Right?
But if I had done this one, I
would also use up 4 pounds of
my allotment.
And so, which of these I take
or don't take is independent
of how I got here.
I do have to keep track of
which items are still
available to me.
But I don't care how I've
used up those 4 pounds.
And obviously, there are a lot
of ways to choose two that
will use up 4 pounds
here, right?
But the solution to this part
of the problem will be
independent of which
two I took.
That make sense now?
Therefore, as long as there is
a prefix of my list of items,
such that multiple things add up
to the same weight, I will
have overlapping subproblems.
Now you could imagine a
situation in which no
combination added to the same
weight, in which case dynamic
programming wouldn't
buy me anything.
It would still find the right
answer, but it wouldn't speed
anything up.
But in practice, for most 0-1
knapsack problems-- they may
not be this simple--
but you could expect--
and we'll see this complexity
later--
that as long as your possible
weights are being chosen from
a relatively small set, you'll
have many things add up to the
same thing--
particularly as you get further
down this list and
have a lot longer prefix
to consider.
So indeed I do have overlapping
subproblems.
That answer the question?
All right, now.
People feel better about
what's going on?
OK.
Maybe looking at some code
will make it even
clearer, and maybe not.
Anyway, I do appreciate
the questions.
Since it's sometimes hard for me
to appreciate what's coming
across and what's not
coming across.
You should get rewarded for
good questions, as well as
good answers.
All right, so now
let's look at a
dynamic programming solution.
I've just taken the
previously--
the example we looked at
before was solve--
made it fast solve.
And I've added a parameter
of memo.
This is the same kind of trick
we used last time for our
shortest path problem.
I should point out
that I'm using--
this calls to mind a dirty,
little secret of Python, one I
have previously been hiding
because it's so ugly I just
hate to talk about it.
But I figured at some point,
honesty is the right policy.
What I'd like is the first
time I call fast solve, I
shouldn't have to know that
there's even a memo.
Fast solve should have the
same interface as solve.
The items to consider and the
available weight, and that's
all you should need to know.
Because the memo is part of the
implementation, not part
of the specification
of solving the
0-1 knapsack problem.
We've made that argument
several times,
earlier in the semester.
And so you might think that what
I should therefore do is
to initialize the memo to,
say the empty dictionary.
I'm going to use dictionaries
for memos, as before.
And then just check and if it's
the empty one, that means
it's the first--
I can know whether it's
the-- it'll work fine
for the first call.
Well it doesn't work fine.
And here's the dirty,
little secret.
In Python, when you have a
parameter with a default
value, that default value
is evaluated once.
So the way the Python system
works is it will process all
of the def statements
and evaluate the
right-hand side here once.
And then every time the function
is called, without
this optional argument, it will
use the value it found
when it evaluated the
def statement.
Now if this value is immutable,
it doesn't matter.
None will be none forever.
28 will be 28 forever.
3.7 will be 3.7 forever.
But if this is a mutable value,
for example a dict,
then what will happen is it will
create an object which
will be initially an
empty dictionary.
But then every time fast solve
is called without this
argument, it will access
the same object.
So if I call fast solve to solve
one problem, and in the
course of that, it builds
up a big dictionary.
And then I call it again to
solve another problem, instead
of starting with the empty
dictionary, it will start with
the same object it started with
the first time, which is
by now a dictionary filled
with values.
And so I will get the
wrong answer.
This is a subtlety, and it's a
common kind of bug in Python.
And I confess to having been
bitten by it very recently, as
in yesterday, myself.
So it's worth remembering.
And there's a simple workaround,
which is the
default value is the
immutable value.
I chose none.
And what I say when I enter it
is if the memo is none, it
means it's been invoked.
And now I'll initialize it
to the empty dictionary.
And now every time it will get
a new one, because we know
what this statement says is
allocate a new object of type
dict, and initialize
it to empty.
This will happen dynamically
when the thing is invoked,
rather than statically
at the time Python
processes the diffs.
It's a silly little problem.
I hate to bring it up.
I don't think it should
work that way, but it
does work that way.
So we're stuck.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
You've have to speak
more loudly.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, why doesn't
my first call--
So the question is when I go to
test it, say, why don't I
start by calling it with fast
solve in an empty dictionary?
And it's because, as we'll see
when I get there, I want solve
and fast solve, in this case,
to have the same interface.
And in fact, you can say I want
them to have the same
specification.
Because in fact, imagine that
you wrote a program that
called solve many times.
And it was slow, and then
you took 6.00--
So, I know why it's
slow, because I've
used a stupid solve.
Let me use dynamic
programming.
I want to then be able to not
name the new one fast solve,
but replace the old solve
by the new solve.
And have all the programs that
you solve still work.
That will not happen if I insist
that the new solve has
an extra argument.
Now I could put what's called
a wrapper in and call solve,
and then have it call fast solve
with the extra argument.
And that would work too.
That would be an equally
good solution to
address this problem.
But does that make sense?
So either one would work.
I chose this one but what
wouldn't work in a practical
engineering sense is to change
the specification of solve.
All right?
So it's a silly little thing,
but since people do get bitten
by it, I figure I should
tell you about it.
And I guess while I'm on the
subject of silly little
things, I'll tell you one more
thing before we go back to
this algorithm.
Down here in the place where
I'm testing it, you'll note
that I've imported something
called sys, and then said
sys.setrecursionlimit to 2000.
In Python, there's a maximum
depth of recursion.
When this is exceeded, it
raises an exception--
depth exceeded.
As it happens, the default
value for that
is some tiny number--
I forget what it is--
such that when I run this on an
interesting size example,
it crashes that exception.
So all I'm doing here
is saying no, I
know what I'm doing.
It's OK to recurse to
a greater depth.
And I've set it to 2000
here, which is
plenty for what I need.
I could set it to 20,000.
I could set it to 50,000.
Again, if you're writing a
serious program, you'll
probably find that the default
value for the depth of
recursion is not enough, and
you might want to reset it.
I don't expect you to remember
how to do this.
I expect you to remember
that it's possible.
And if you need to do it, you
can Google "recursion limit
Python" and it will tell
you how to change it.
But again, I've found
in testing this, the
default was too small.
Ok.
Let's go look at the code
now for fast solve.
It's got the items to consider,
what's available,
the available weight,
and a memo.
And I'm going to keep track
of the number of calls.
Just for pedagogical
reasons, we'll want
to review that later.
OK, so I'll initialize
the memo if it's
the first time through.
And then the first thing I'll do
is I'm going to code what I
have available essentially the
way I've coded it here-- so
what items are remaining
by using an index.
So my items are going to
be a set of lists.
And I'm going to just sort
of keep track of
where I am in the list--
just march through exactly the
way I'd marched through here.
And so if the list of
things to consider,
the length of it--
because every time the length
is the same, it
will be the same list.
Since I'm systematically
examining a prefix.
I'm not shuffling the
list each time.
So the length can be used
to tell me what I've
already looked at.
So if I've looked at that
sublist before, with this
available weight, it will
be in the memo.
And I'll just look
up the solution--
result equals memo of
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to consider avail.
So those will be my keys
for my dictionary.
The key will be a pair of
essentially which items I have
left to consider, which is coded
by a number, and the
amount of weight,
another number.
Or if there's nothing left to
consider, or there's no weight
available, then I'll return
0 and the empty tuple--
no value, didn't
take anything.
Otherwise, I'm now in the
interesting case.
If to consider subzero, the
first one here, if the weight
of that is greater than what I
have available, then I know I
can't take it.
Right?
So I'll just lop it off and call
fast solve recursively
with the remaining list--
same old value of avail
and the same old memo.
Otherwise, well now I have an
option of taking the first
element in the list.
I'll set the item to that
element, and I'll
consider taking it.
So I'll call fast solve
with to consider
without the first item.
But the amount of weight will
be available now is what was
available before minus the
weight of that item.
This is my left branch,
if you will, where I
decide to take the item.
And so now I'm solving
a smaller problem.
The list is smaller, and
I have less weight.
The next thing I'll do is
consider not taking the item.
So I'll call fast solve
again with the
remainder of the list.
But avail and memo
are not changed.
That's the right branch.
And you'll remember our decision
tree the right branch
avail and weight were
never changed.
Because I elected not
to take that item.
Then I'll just choose the
better of the two
alternatives, as before.
And when I'm done, I'll update
the memo with the solution to
the problem I just solved.
All right?
So it's exactly the same as
the recursive solution you
looked at a few weeks ago.
Except I've added this notion
of a memo to keep track of
what we've already done.
Well let's see how
well it works.
So I've got this test program.
Just so things are repeatable,
I'd set the C to 0 --
doesn't matter what I set it to,
this just says instead of
getting a random value each
time, I'll get the same C so
I'll get the same sequence of
pseudo-random numbers--
makes it easier to debug.
I'll have this global
variable num calls.
I'm arbitrarily setting the
capacity to eight times the
maximum weight.
So I'm saying the maximum
value of an item is 10.
The maximum weight is 10.
This just says runs slowly is
false, as in don't run the
slow version.
Run only the fast version.
We'll come back to that.
I set the capacity of
the Knapsack to 8
times the max weight.
And then for the number of
items-- and I'm just going to
go through a different
number of items,
4, 8 16, up to 1024--
I'm going to call build
many items.
Again, we've seen this
program before.
That just takes a number of
items, a maximum value, and a
maximum weight, and builds some
set of items, choosing
the values and weights at random
from the ones we've
offered it.
This saves me.
I wasn't going to type a
set of 1024 items, I
guarantee you that.
If it runs slowly, then I'm
going to test it on both fast
solve and solve.
Notice that these are the names
of the functions, not
invocations of the functions.
Because remember functions,
like everything else in
Python, are just objects.
Otherwise, my tests will be
only the tuple fast solve.
And then for each function in
tests, I'm going to set the
number of calls to 0.
I'm going to load up a timer,
just because I'm curious how
long it takes.
And then I'll call the func.
Notice again, getting back to
what we talked about before,
both fast solve and
solve get called
with the same arguments.
I could not have done this
trick if fast solve had
required an extra parameter.
And then I'll just see
how well it did.
So let's start with this
equal to true.
So in that case we'll
test both of them.
And let's see how we do.
So it's chugging along.
And we see that if I have 4
items, fast solve made 29
calls, took this much time.
The good news, by the way,
you'll notice that fast solve
and solve gave me the same
value each time.
We would hope so, right?
Because they're both supposed
to find an optimal solution.
They could find different
sets of items.
That would be OK.
But they better add up
to the same value.
But we seem to be stuck here.
So you'll notice at 16,
Solve made 131,000
calls, fast solve 3,500--
only took a third of a second.
But we seem to be kind
of stuck at--
actually, fast solve
only made 1,200.
At 32, fast solve made
3,500 calls.
But solve seems to be stuck.
Should this be a shocker that
going from 16 to 32 made a big
difference?
Well remember here we're talking
about 2 to the 16
possibilities to investigate,
which is not a huge number.
But now we're at 2 to the 32,
which is quite a large number.
And so we could wait quite
a long time for solve to
actually finish.
And in fact, we're not going
to wait that long.
We'll interrupt it.
So let's see how well
fast solve works.
We just call that.
So we'll set this to false.
It says don't run slowly, i.e.
Don't call solve.
So not only did we not get stuck
at 32 items way up here,
we didn't get stuck
at 1024 items.
Huge difference, right?
Instead of only being able to
process a set of 16, we can
process a set of over 1,000.
And in fact, I don't know how
much higher we can go.
I didn't try anything bigger.
But even this--
big difference between getting
stuck here and not getting
stuck here.
And in fact, not only did
not get stuck, it
was only two seconds.
So let's ask ourselves
the question-- how
fast is this growing?
Not very fast--
more or less, what we see
here-- and this is not
something we can guarantee.
But in this case, what we see is
as we double the number of
items, the number of calls
kind of doubles as well.
So we're actually growing
pretty slowly.
Well, OK that's good.
But suppose we want to look at
it a little bit more carefully
and consider the question of
what does govern the running
time of fast solve.
Well we know that looking
things up in the dict is
constant time.
So that's OK.
So what's going to govern it is
every time we have to add
an element to the memo, it's
going to slow us down.
Because you're gonna have
to solve a problem.
Every time we can just look
something up in the memo,
we'll get our answer back
instantaneously.
So if we think about the running
time, it's going to be
related to how many different
key value pairs might we have
to compute for the memo.
Well what governs that?
So we know that the keys in
the memo are pairs of to
consider and avail.
And so we know that the number
of possible different keys
will be the number of possible
values in to consider,
multiplied by the number of
possible values of avail.
Right?
How many possible values of
to consider are there?
What governs that?
That's the easy question.
Number of items, right?
Because I'm just marching across
this list, chopping off
one item at a time.
At most I can chop off
n items, if the list
is of length n.
Avail is more complicated.
What does avail depend upon?
It depends upon, well, the
initial available weight.
If the initial available weight
is 0, well then it's
gonna end really quickly.
If it's really big, I might
have to churn longer.
But it also depends--
and this is the key thing--
on the number of different
weights, that sets of items
can add up to.
Because you'll recall the whole
secret here was that we
said that different sets of
items could actually have the
same total weight.
And that's why we had this
business of overlapping
subproblems.
Now here, since I only had 10
possible weights, that tells
me that I can't have very many
different combinations.
Right?
That any set of say, one item
has to be 0 through 10, or 0
through 9, I forget
which it was.
But either way, that means
that alI only have 10
different possible sums
for sets of length 1.
Whereas if my weights ranged
over 100, I would have 100
different possibilities
for sets of length 1.
So that's an important factor
in governing it.
So it's a complicated situation,
but just to see
what happens, try and remember
how long this took for 1024.
It took 2.2 seconds.
I'm going to allow 20
different weights.
And let's see what happens.
It took roughly twice as long.
So that's sort of what we
would have expected.
So again, we're going to
see the running time
is related to that.
So we can see that
it's actually a
fairly complicated thing.
Suppose I did something really
nasty and went up here where I
built my items--
so here you'll see, when I built
my items I chose the
weight between 1
and max weight.
And these were all integers--
ints.
Suppose instead of
that, I do this.
So here after I choose my value
between 1 and 10, I'm
going to multiply it by some
random number between 0 and 1.
We've all seen random.random.
So now how many possible
different weights
am I going to have?
A huge number, right?
The number of random numbers,
real floats between 0 and 1 is
close to infinite, right?
And so in fact, now I'm going
to see that with reasonable
probability, every single item
will have a different weight.
And so, things adding up to the
same could still happen,
even if they're all different.
But it's not very probable.
So let's see what happens
when I run it now.
It's slowing down
pretty quickly.
Pretty much where the other
one stopped right?
Remember we got through
16 with Slowsolve
but not through 32?
Because effectively, I've now
reduced the fast solve to the
same as solve.
It will never find anything
in the memo, so it's doing
exactly the same amount of
work that solve did.
And it will run very slowly.
OK, life is hard.
But this is what you'd expect,
because deep down we know the
0-1 knapsack problem is
exponential, inherently
exponential.
And while I think dynamic
programming is kind of
miraculous how well it usually
works, it's not miraculous in
the liturgical sense, right?
It's not actually performing
a miracle in solving an
exponential problem
in linear time.
It can in all things go bad.
The exponential, and that's
what it is here.
This kind of algorithm is called
pseudo-polynomial.
It kind of runs in polynomial
time, but not when things are
really bad.
And I won't go into the details
of pseudo-polynomial,
but if any of you are in Course
6, you'll hear about it
in 6.006 and 6.046.
OK, we can adjourn.
I'll see you all on Thursday.
And we're not going to
wait for this to
finish, because it won't.